all right human rights activists and
United Nations messenger of peace Malala
yousufzai will meet with the Canadian
Prime Minister and addressed the
country's parliament today she became
the youngest Nobel Peace Prize winner
after surviving a Taliban assassination
attack Yousef sy wrote a best-selling
book the audio version won a Grammy
Award and over the next six month she'll
advocate for the education of women and
girls by visiting Latin America the
Middle East North America Europe and
Africa on what she's calling her girl
power trip at the same time the 19 year
old is trying to figure out her college
plans for the fall and we talked to her
at the UN about her global mission of
Education preventing war and her message
to President Trump
well welcome we're gonna sit down right
here the UN rarely shuts down the
General Assembly Hall for a television
interview but for Malala yousufzai the
world body made an exception the
survivor of a 2012 Taliban attack has
demonstrated comfort on the global stage
addressing the most complex issues
President Trump
twice tried to issue an immigration ban
or a travel ban on refugees from
majority Muslim countries what message
do you think that sent well you win
president and Muslim majority countries
that was very disappointing and I was
deeply hurt because I'm a Muslim and to
me it just seemed like directly blaming
Muslims and that is not a solution that
is just making an excuse and hiding from
the real problems I think he needs to
understand that you need to meet the
people you need to you need to see the
refugee people Malala has done just that
spending her 19th birthday with Somalian
refugees in Kenya she also visited a
Syrian refugee camp in Jordan they are
dying whether they're in Syria or any
other country there they're dying
they're being killed and if you don't
open the doors
if you don't welcome them they would be
killed so it's important that he
understand that these people are in the
and and I have seen them I have went to
refugee camp and I think he needs to go
to this refugee camp you think President
Trump needs to go to a refugee camp I
definitely agree with that
president Donald Trump needs to go and
see refugee children he needs to go and
visit the refugee camps he needs to know
what the real life is like in a refugee
camp
we saw the horrifying images of the
chemical attack in Syria and the u.s.
later bombed a Syrian Air Base and what
the White House called a proportional
response did you see those pictures it
is shocking what's happening in Syria
and but we need to remember that this
happens each and every day whether
that's through chemical weapon or any
other weapon the number of people who
have been killed is in hundreds and
thousands and it has been happening for
more than five to six years and and the
world is being is being silent and I
think we need to remind our leaders that
this is a serious issue we need to think
ahead we need to think about preventing
Wars from starting as well and I think
for that investment in education is the
key investing especially in the
education of women and girls there's a
direct relationship between illiteracy
and terrorism with education comes
questioning with education comes
critical thinking with the education
comes more opportunities people go
forward people people see in the world
from a different perspective but Malala
there are a hundred and thirty million
girls who do not have access to school
it is it is shocking that 130 million
girls are not in school and when we talk
about going forward and achieving like
development it is not possible without
empowering these hundred thirty million
girls but I just wonder like why do
these leaders not see this Malala is
that because he started with a blog for
the BBC she spoke out about the Taliban
suppression of girls in Pakistan it made
her a target four and a half years ago
when Taliban militants shot her in the
head on her school bus when it's hitting
me district we first spoke with her a
year later the
in who targeted you is now the head of
the Taliban does that scare you I'm not
scared of the Taliban I thought I might
be afraid of course and like dragons and
those things but I'm not afraid of the
Taliban her bravery earned her the Nobel
Peace Prize in 2014 it is an enormous
pleasure and earlier this week the
United Nations secretary-general
bestowed his highest honor I am proud to
designate you the youngest ever United
Nations messenger of peace with a
special focus on girls education placing
her among an elite group of public
figures raising awareness on behalf of
the UN for Malala it was an emotional
return had a historic moment here when I
spoke at the UN and I gave my speech
after the attack and it was my first
kind of appearance one child one teacher
one book and one pen can change the
world she's still working to change the
world by leading the way that is my
campaign to make sure that the guys
voices a heart
yesterday she spoke at a school in
Lancaster Pennsylvania it's a farming
community of 60,000 with an outsize
population of resettled refugees why did
you want to visit Lancaster Pennsylvania
to the world sometimes especially right
now due to the political situation
people have a different image of America
right now a bit unwelcoming image they
call Lancaster America's refugee capital
yes and and I think Lancaster being an
American refugee capital is giving a
very positive message to the world
about American people so I'm hopeful
that people will follow the city back in
her adopted home in the UK Malala is
finishing up her final exams she tells
us she'd like to attend the alma mater
of her hero benazir bhutto Pakistan's
first female prime minister so I had an
interview for Oxford and it was the
hardest interview the
list of your life it was why because
they asked of really hard questions I
find it hard to believe that anything is
hard for you Malala no but it's
different it's not a TV interview it's a
different interview
let's go hard question yeah a lot of
academic questions they could have been
questions yeah but you would like to go
to Oxford if I get the goods yeah if you
get the grades yeah but you've said you
would like to be Prime Minister one day
I did say well I'm not sure let's see
this I see what I thought he does yeah
you're dialing back on that I'm not sure
it's just a bit too much of it too much
yeah I'm gonna be focused on my
University no my University oh I mean
you know she's not given an interview in
a couple of years of television
interview I interviewed her three and a
half years ago she just doesn't do
interviews and yet she is the most
famous teenager in the world
it's amazing that she's 19 years old do
you think about how much she's
accomplished at this young age what she
has in store is just unbelievable
welcomed by world leaders with the
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
other world leaders she had met the Oval
Office with President Obama so she's
gonna focus on getting into Oxford she
said she's got to get three A's on her
final exams but it's hard to believe
they wouldn't let her in it was not
gonna make it exactly and if not I'm
sure Harvard and Stanford guys exactly
waiting for her we have more from
malala's interview on our CBS this
morning podcast find out how she plans
to use her new UN honor to achieve her
goals all around the world just search
for CBS this morning on iTunes or
Apple's podcast app